[Music]  from my blood  come the prince that was promised  and his will be the song  of ice and fire  the burden of this knowledge  [Music]  is larger than the throne  it is larger than you  the king chose ramira  the realm will not accept her  men will soon put the realm to the torch  and see a woman ascend the iron throne  i will be queen of the seven kingdoms  [Music]  made as you wish  but i am cold in my grave  [Music]  dreams didn't make us kings  [Music]  dragons did  but the people remember  the ancient strength of house targaryen  no king has ever lived that hasn't had  to forfeit the lives of a few to protect  the many  you are no conqueror you are a plague  our houses are bound by a common cause  perhaps  but there will be blood  [Music]  you